So let's summarize the big ideas of all-pairs N-body include.
This might not be the most efficient algorithm. It's not.
But it's both simple and high performance.
So if you implement this, you'll find that you're actually able
to sustain a significant fraction of the peak theoretical value of the GPU.
The real advantage here is that we have a very large amount of parallelism in this problem
that we're able to exploit well in our implementation.
The interesting part of this implementation is how to structure the ample parallelism
that is available in this problem.
And the big idea we discussed is the tradeoff
between exploiting the maximum amount of parallelism and doing more work per thread.
And there's many problems where increasing the amount of work per thread
and reducing the amount of parallelism is really the right thing to do
because of the speed of communicating results within a single thread
is faster than communicating between threads.